the fundraising website GoFundMe has
banned anti-vaccine campaigns from
raising money for campaigns to spread
misinformation about vaccines like for
example raising money on GoFundMe to buy
Facebook or Twitter ads to spread
anti-vaxxer propaganda this is really
good news this is not a free speech
issue this is not a censorship issue
this is GoFundMe establishing their
Terms of Service and enforcing their
Terms of Service and terms and
conditions a spokesperson for GoFundMe
said quote campaigns raising money to
promote misinformation about vaccines
violate GoFundMe Terms of Service and
will be removed from the platform we are
conducting a thorough review and will
remove any campaigns currently on the
platform this is a movement whose total
irresponsibility and misunderstanding of
science or lack of understanding of
science is leading to real-world
consequences I've told you about
multiple outbreaks of measles around the
world mostly kids in the United States
they are coming from some very specific
anti vaccine sort of enclaves I don't
even want to call them stronghold
enclaves I think is a better better term
there are not a ton of campaigns on
GoFundMe that are raising money for anti
vaccine stuff GoFundMe estimates that in
total these campaigns have raised about
a hundred and seventy thousand dollars
only ten campaigns have been removed so
far and it's really important to
understand that all sketchy
pseudoscience and whacky medicine stuff
is against the Terms of Service oh go of
GoFundMe so if you think that they are
claiming to be against disinformation
related to science and medicine but
they're only targeting anti vaccine
campaigns that's wrong because GoFundMe
has removed campaigns there was a German
cancer clinic claiming that they can use
vitamins and ozone therapy to treat or
cure cancer that was removed other
pseudoscience sham medicine stuff has
been removed so I applaud GoFundMe this
is a worthy
effort GoFundMe is banning anti-vaccine
disinformation campaigns Facebook and
YouTube have announced they're going to
try to cut down on the amount of
anti-vaxxer stuff on their websites
amazon has started to pull some
anti-vaccine books and documentaries and
i see the anti-vaccine movement as a
movement that has surfaced from the
success of vaccines and what i mean by
that is because there has been an almost
total eradication of certain diseases
measles polio by vaccines people start
to forget that before we had these
vaccines these were really serious
life-threatening conditions for a lot of
people so they start to take the
approach that hey no one's getting this
stuff why why do we even need vaccines
the vaccines are actually what the
problem is nobody's getting polio or
measles anymore well that's thanks to
the vaccines and then you combine that
with a few of these very popular data
points like that bogus MMR vaccine
autism study done by Andrew Wakefield
when you dig into it you remember oh the
study has been debunked and retracted
and Andrew Wakefield lost his medical
license you realize how compelling this
stuff is to a lot of people despite
there being no actual good evidence for
the anti vaccine conclusions I I do
believe Pat that this is the right
approach
in my experience arguing with individual
anti-vaxxers is not very effective I do
think that enforcing Terms of Service to
prevent the disinformation from
spreading is probably a better approach
I was gonna ask do you think we're
winning on this front and not just
because GoFundMe won't allow
anti-vaxxers to spread misinformation on
their website anymore
or any of the YouTube and Facebook stuff
but just because you know there are more
jurisdictions now that are requiring
students be vaccinated in or in order to
enter public schools the fact that we're
seeing outbreaks of perfectly terrible
diseases now in these anti-vaxxer
strongholds like maybe this anti-vaxxer
movement is dying out and people are
starting to
go back the other way in favor of
vaccines once again I hope that that's
true but you know the thing is if you're
someone who can't get vaccinated because
of a medical condition or you were
vaccinated but vaccines aren't 100%
effective and because of some anti VAX
you unfortunately caught one of these
diseases from someone else on the basis
of anti vaccine ology even if we're
winning in total those individual cases
are still tragic so I I hope that we are
moving in the right direction on this
issue but this stuff can be strong and
especially as I've mentioned with anteye
VAX where there are people on the left
and right who have ended up anti-vaxxer
different reasons some for government
scepticism some for big pharma
skepticism that can actually make the
movement continue to sort of breathe
oxygen and grow it for some time but I I
do hope that this is eventually a battle
that will be one won by science I think
it's important to say I am thrilled to
tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink asam / Pakman
blinka is a really unique service for
your phone tablet and web browser and it
is incredibly useful for people like me
who love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube
i've put a link in the description i
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it
you
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa k ma n